in this video I want to start to answer
the question of how did the environment
and how did political factors impact
trade and that is a really big question
that we're not going to answer in one
video but I want to use a specific
example to illustrate the role of
environment and the role of politics in
shaping trade so I want to start in
burka which is roughly here in
present-day Sweden and the reason I
start here is that in the late 1800s a
team of archaeologists working in this
site uncovered a woman's gray of among
other things and found in that gray of
the ring that we see in the photo here
and they've dated this grave and the
ring they found in it - somewhere in the
ninth century so somewhere in between
the years 800 and 900 or so and we can
see in our bigger timeline that that
falls right into what's called the
Viking Age and the Vikings were were
people living in Scandinavia in this
region shaded in red they weren't a
single political entity there were a lot
of smaller more independent communities
but they shared a lot of cultural
characteristics so back to our ring
firstly it's made of silver
secondly the the bead that's set into it
is made of a really high-quality glass
and that's of a higher quality than
anything that archaeologists have found
in Scandinavia from this time period so
those two facts would indicate that the
ring is probably from somewhere else
there's an inscription on the ring it's
kind of hard to see but if you look
closely you can sort of make it out and
linguists and archaeologists who have
looked at this are fairly certain that
this is a form of old Arabic script and
they think it says something along the
lines of - or for Allah and I mentioned
that the Vikings shared a lot of
cultural characteristics and one of
those characteristics was that they all
spoke Norse languages so an Arabic
inscription on the ring implies really
strongly that the ring did not come from
Scandinavia so that should raise the
question for you of where did this ring
come from and how did it end up in burka
so the first factor we can look at to
try and figure out where this ring came
from and how it got here is to look at
the
medical context the political context at
any given time is going to determine
where and what goods are traded so think
about it like this if there are two
groups of people and they have a
relatively good political relationship
it's more likely that they're going to
trade with each other too so if we look
at the political situation broadly
speaking during the Viking Age we have
three major empires the first in purple
we have the Byzantine Empire which was
what was left of the Roman Empire at
this time we have in yellow the abasa
della fete and this is an Islamic empire
that was founded in about 750 and then
we have in blue the Carolingian Empire
in Europe and that's named after
Charlemagne who in Latin is careless
Magnus so Carolyn Jian comes from that
and I should point out on the timeline
the Carolingian Empire does continue
after Charlemagne's death it just
becomes a little bit more fractured
politically empires tend to have large
cities they can support larger
concentrations of people which means
larger concentrations of wealth which in
turn means that there is more demand so
cities become attractive to traders
because you have a lot of customers in
one spot and those Imperial cities
especially tend to concentrate a lot of
wealth if they are the seat of
government too so I'm going to pull our
cities onto the map and as we look
around here we can see a Aachen is the
capital of the Carolingian Empire which
is actually geographically quite close
to the Vikings we have Constantinople is
the Byzantine capital and then we have
Baghdad which is the ambassador and when
we look at those three empires in those
three cities specifically only one of
them speaks Arabic and writes Arabic and
that would be the Ambassador fate so
that would mean that the most likely
place of origin for this ring was
somewhere in the abasa della fete and
yellow down here so we want to think
about why would the Vikings be trading
with the empire that's farthest away
from that well part of the answer is
political so if we look at the
relationship between the Vikings and the
Carolingians for example one of
Charlemagne's big projects as the ruler
of the care
when Empire was to wage war against and
try to convert the pagans who were
living on the northeastern edge of his
empire so there's this ongoing conflict
between Charlemagne and and
non-christians including the Vikings and
that tends to hurt the the potential
economic relationships that they could
have and you actually see the Vikings
raid the coast of the Carolingian Empire
in the 9th century as well so the
Vikings are trading with the Byzantines
and with the Ambassador what they're
engaging in is what we call
long-distance trade so when we talk
about long-distance trade what we
usually see our luxury goods and luxury
goods are goods that are rare and
expensive and so in all of these empires
what we see is is the political context
the fact that they have large powerful
empires makes it likely that they have
more advanced technology which means
that they're able to produce
higher-quality
more technologically advanced goods but
then we have to ask what are the Vikings
have that they would be trading with
these more advanced empires well one
thing we can point out here is that the
Vikings in Scandinavia are in a very
different climate than we have down in
the Byzantine Empire in the abasa della
fate and to a certain extent different
than even what the Carolingians have
although we pointed out some of the
political issues prevented more trade
from occurring between them and the
point we would make about the different
climates is that climates determine what
resources are available so if we look at
what the Vikings are trading we see
things that are somewhat unique to their
climate and when we talk about the
Viking traders a lot of what they're
doing is actually coming across the
Baltic Sea into this region here the
Baltic region we'd call that and they
are obtaining goods such as timber and
specifically the timber they want are
from pine trees and pines in the Baltic
tend to grow very tall and straight and
that makes them really attractive for
building material also it's much colder
in this climate and animals for burying
mammals especially will tend to grow
nicer thicker coats if they live in cold
climates and that makes them more
attractive that
and as potential clothing items another
resource we see frequently in the Baltic
region is amber and that is a dried tree
resin and that can be polished and
shaped into stones for for jewelry for
decoration as well
the Vikings also do engage in in the
slave trade they'll kidnap and take
people from this region and then trade
them as slaves with these Imperial
capitals that is not something that's
necessarily influenced by the
environment but it is also part of this
trade some of the some of the most
popular items that the Vikings are
trading for are things like fabrics
especially silk which is produced in
these empires I also mentioned glass
earlier we saw the glass inset in the
ring they also are making glass vessels
like drinking glasses you can see a
picture of one here and that is going to
be of a much better quality than
anything that the Vikings are able to
produce so that that glass becomes an
attractive technology there's a lot of
silver coming out of especially the
abbasid caliphate and one of the reasons
that they know this trade was occurring
more broadly is that in the baltic
region and along some of the travel
routes between the baltic and the
ambassador caliphate archaeologists have
found hordes or large collections of
silver Abbasid coins and so we see here
both silver and glass the elements of
that ring that we discovered are are
things that are being traded for by the
Vikings coming from this region so we
see the climate impacting to a certain
extent what goods exist in different
regions so there's an environmental
impact there we also see geography or
environment affecting the transportation
of goods so what I'm going to do next is
pull in the commonly used trade routes
at this time and this helps us to
understand how these goods actually move
between these places so we see that the
major trade routes between the the
Baltic region and the Byzantines and the
Ambassador follow major river systems
and the Vikings are able to take
advantage of these river systems in part
because of the technology that they
possess so again we see the environment
playing a role in trade in determining
what routes are our
convenient to transport goods and one
other point I would make about these
routes that develop is we see these
cities of Novgorod of Kiev and a vulgar
that pop up along these trade routes and
these these cities sort of grow because
the trade routes exist this these cities
themselves become centers of trade over
time so to come back to our ring that we
started the video with hopefully this is
looking less like an anomalous a strange
find and more like the natural result of
the the existing trade networks that
were in place because of the
environmental because of the political
conditions at this time